- This is this, this is, is this zoom?
- This is zoom.
- You are now my official favorite person
to come on the show you just flow.
I was like, oh my God, it's zoom.
- It's just zoom.
That's what it is forever.
- This is what I look like forever.
- Right?
- Yeah. I had like yoga
pants that I did not.
You do yoga. I don't.
I just wore them and I wore tennis shoes.
And then I'd like a pretty blouse.
- Yeah. That's what it's about
You're just like, okay, I'm presentable.
- I love it.
- But why would I do anything else?
(laughing)
Rather than this, why?
There's no reason for it.
- Like, once you've seen it
My favorite was people
would be like, oh, just
cause it's pandemic to,
oh, this is what pandemic did to me
I'm like, this is like a
Thursday in 2018 for me.
(laughing)
I'm like, this is yeah, totally.
It's COVID. That's what it was.
So wait, you have a two year old now.
- I do.
- So how is that? Are you
exhausted? Or you love it?
(cheering)
- I love it.
- You love every minute.
- Mean, I, I feel like
it's the best thing that I,
well, it is, I don't feel like it.
I know it's the best thing
I've ever done in life and
yeah, it's the most, it's really,
- But wait too.
So like you don't have those
moments where you're like,
(nervous laughing)
- I don't.
I feel like as a parent, that's
your job is to just be like
okay, so what are you feeling here?
How is it?
There's something there.
Kids are always just
trying to express a feeling
- Yes!
- they're not actively trying to be bad.
They're just trying to,
- But when they can't communicate,
they get so frustrated.
- Exactly. So what is it?
I do my mom checklist.
Did she eat? Is she tired?
What I'm like, what time is it?
You know?
- Yeah.
- When was the last time she ate?
When is she, you know, when is nap?
- Yeah.
- You know, and you just
kind of go start there
and then you go, like, what just happened?
Is there something she's
trying to communicate to me?
And I just have, you know,
I feel like as a parent
my job is to just help her find the words
to her, emotions, her
experience, what she's going
through and be able to
help her identify that
and then move through it.
And what does she need from me
and what does she need from herself?
And is this something she can take care
of herself that she can talk?
- Can we talk every week? Or Like,
- Yeah.
- Like are you like
naturally a patient person?
- I, you know, look it,
I think that because I'm
an older parent and I've already, you know
I really worked hard to get a child.
It's not like it just happened to me
- I'm not like a young parent.
- You know, I know, but
you know, I think it's just
a different thing when I've
also been able, I'm very
fortunate to have been able
to take the time to do it.
- Yeah.
- And be there with her.
And that's like just the
hugest blessing that I have
- That's great though.
You have like the most
amazing outlook on that.
- It's challenging, but you know
what's also really imperative
is to repair, you know?
So like if you do break, like blow
up just to repair that and say
oh my God, mommy lost (bleep)
- Oh, that's what
(laughing)
Yeah. No, that's what,
no, that's what you do.
- And just like, I, I didn't
mean to say that to you.
Yeah. If I hurt your feelings or
if I made you feel, if I upset you.
- Yeah.
- I just want you to
know mommy's human too.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- I will say I'm lucky.
Like I'm very, my kids are
very communicative to me
in that sense.
Like we're very open
about like, I, I'm not
like afraid to say, oh
man, mommy messed up.
Like I should have handled it this way.
But you know, like how,
like sometimes you get so
frustrated you don't,
that happens to mommy too.
- Yeah.
- You know, I was like, so
we just need to do better.
So we, we do that, but it's, you know what
I think this conversation deserves
- What?
- Some of your wine.
- Okay.
(cheering and laughing)
- You know, I'm like, I think
I think that we should have a drink.
- Cheers to you mommy
- To being a great mom.
(cheering)
- So this is actually your wine.
So any woman that makes
wine is a friend of mine.
So what, what led you to this venture?
- My girlfriend and I, Catherine Power.
- Oh
- We didn't, we didn't
know what was in our wine.
You know, we didn't know
what was in it because
- Sorry, that was my first taste.
That was real good.
- I it's really good.
- Yeah. That was my first taste
- I mean, it's supposed to be good.
- Yeah.
- It's, you know, we didn't
know what was in our wine
because it's not disclosed.
There's no labeling on wine.
It's one of the only
consumables that doesn't have
an ingredient list.
And so we kind of took a
deep dive into wine making
and found that there are a plethora
- Yeah.
- Of additives that can be utilized
in the wine making process
for various different reasons.
- Yeah.
- That's why I don't
feel that on French wine
they don't do those additives.
- Well, our Rose is French
- Okay.
- And so is our red and
- I did not really even put that together
- White is Spanish and
it's really delicious.
- It is.
- And we did cans because you know
we advocate moderation at Avaline.
We're not a party. You know, brand.
- You don't want anybody holding
someone's hair, you know?
- Exactly.
Not at all.
- Yeah.
- You know, and you know
sometimes you go to the,
you know, you wanna go to dinner and
this fits perfectly in a
Fanny pack. I will say.
(laughing)
- Not that I, I've heard
from a friend, you know
- Going to a
- Catch her on a hike.
She's like, hold a minute, you know
- When I go to dinner with a
girlfriend who's I know is not
gonna be having a glass
of wine and I wanna just
have a glass of wine.
I pop one of these into my bag
- Yeah.
- I just have, I get the perfect serving.
It's not more than I, you
know, would drink on my own.
- I like it
- Yeah.
- Yeah. All right. Cheers.
- Cheers.
- It's really nice. Yeah.
(cheering)
- So do wanna taste white?
- This, this is amazing.
I don't drink after people.
- Oh, I haven't drank.
- Oh, you haven't.
- No!
- Well, don't drink after me.
- I won't, Cause I, I
know what it tastes like
I don't need to drink it
- Normally. Okay. I was afraid to do this
because normally I don't
like white wine. That's good!
- Everybody says that
about our white wine.
- They all say don't like white wine.
- I normally don't drink it.
Now I look like that girl at the party.
(laughing)
- I'll hold your hair,
Kelly. I'll hold your hair.
(laughing)
- It's been a rough two years, Cameron.
No, so I love this video.
We found this.
So here you are sharing
a can with a friend.
Yeah. Which, which is an amazing friend.
I just love that.
Y'all, you've, you've
gotta see the whole video.
Cause I, this is my question
One, have you ever dressed up
from "Something About Mary"
- No!
- For like Halloween or anything?
- No. No, of course not.
- I, that would be the greatest thing
- I told. Actually I totally
told Benny, Benny Drama.
If you guys know him on
Instagram, he's so hilarious.
He's like a genius.
Him and his, his partner, Terry.
We asked them to do something
with us, with Avaline and,
and they came up with this idea.
Yeah. And I was like, you
guys are just too funny.
- I know, but
- Like you're just too funny.
- The upsetting for
people watching though, is
that you look identical to
what you did in the record.
And I'm like, that door
opened and I was like (bleep).
And I was like, can't say that on the show
but I was just like, DAMN.
So wait.
So you've, you've taken
time off, like from acting
you said a minute ago, you like took time.
It's nice to have as a parent as well.
So like taking time off,
like, did you, did you do it
on purpose just to like kind
of get back in your own head
in your own life?
Because sometimes I feel like
in this industry it gets away
from you and you just
feel it can, I don't know.
It can feel like infantilizing.
Like it's, it's people
do so many things for you
that you're like, forget
how to do simple things.
And then you're on the phone
with someone and they're like,
what's your account number?
And I'm like, I don't know.
(laughing)
- Let me call three people.
Like yeah. It just
because sometimes this industry
takes so much from you.
Like the little things
that you don't think about.
Is it nice to get away from that?
And you feel like you're
like your own individual?
- What do you think Kelly?
- Well, well
- being in the middle of the storm.
How do you? What do you think?
- Honestly, I don't feel that way.
I feel like I know everybody sees
like I have a lot of jobs
but actually I cut back
this year and that's why I
I love doing ASC like this
other show with Snoop Dogg
because it was something
I love that I got to do
but it wasn't so time consuming for me.
- Right.
- And it is smarter. Like I
think later in your career
to start choosing little things, like,
look I don't wanna give up on,
I don't wanna give this up.
Yeah. But I wanna, I wanna
do it like in my own time.
- Yeah. I think it goes back
to all the things that are
like the, the big pieces of my life
that I had sort of lost
touch with, you know
doing things for myself,
knowing, you know, I had a house
but I didn't take care of it.
I had dogs, but I didn't
take care of them.
- Yeah.
- I had family, but that I
saw, you know they came to me.
- Yeah. Because it's overwhelming
- You know, just because you're
you are completely consumed
by the work, you know
and on films, it's 12 hour
days. You're on sets for months.
You're owned by the, you know,
the, the project literally.
And so I, you know, I feel
like, I felt like, wow
I really just want to take, I'm very
I'm a very capable person.
And I just wanna exercise those muzzles.
Muzz muzzles
- Muzzles, muzzles
- Muzzles, muzzles again
- Muzzles. Some people do need muzzles
(laughing)
- Those muscles again,
and so it was kind of a reclaiming
of my of myself for
myself and nobody else.
I mean, nobody asked me to do it.
Nobody wanted me to do it, you know
- But that's even more amazing.
You knew that you needed it.
Like I don't, I think like a lot
of people in this industry
too used you keep going
and then you don't even know.
- Yeah.
- Like it took, took something
dramatic in my life to go,
oh my God, I'm like, I've,
I'd been kind of saying it for a minute
but I wasn't listening to myself.
I was listening to others.
- Yeah.
- And then it was just
like, oh no, no, no, no.
We gotta pull back a little bit.
So, but I love working though.
So it's nice to like do stuff.
It's nice to do projects
that you like that are
interesting to and organic in your life.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- And this was, you know, I was
it just was a really fun
project to, to do from home.
We launched it during COVID
we're going on our second year.
- I love it.
- And yeah. So we
- What a time to bring
out an alcoholic beverage.
- Right? Really!
- That was smart.
- It just timed out that way. Honestly.
We were like, oh right now
- I call that God's time.
- Yeah, exactly.
- His will.